What do we mean when we say Spartan?
As an adjective, Spartan means
austere, tough, without luxury.
This comes straight from the ancient
stereotype of the Spartans,
the inhabitants of Sparta
in southern Greece.
The Spartans were the ultimate
warriors, raised from childhood
to endure terrible suffering
and hardship.
The Spartan character
is summed up perfectly
by the ancient accounts
of the Battle of Thermopylae.
In 480 B.C.,
the Persians invaded Greece
and the Spartan King Leonidas,
with 300 Spartans,
held the pass against them
and died in the attempt.
They didn't succeed in stopping
the Persian advance,
merely slowing it down,
buying precious time
for their fellow Greeks
and giving their lives
in the process.
The battle exemplifies so much of
what we admire about the Spartans.
Their loyalty to a cause
bigger than themselves.
Their devotion to liberty and the
preservation of their homeland.
In the course of their fighting
they managed a kind of grim humour,
which is familiar to us today from
all sorts of action heroes whose
pithy one liners are uttered at
the moment of ultimate peril.
For example, when the Persians
demanded that the Spartans
lay down their arms,
Leonidas famously replied...
Likewise, when a hail of lethal
Persian arrows blocked the sun,
Leonidas quipped to his companions...
We can also admire the Spartans'
association with great physical
fitness and toughness and endurance.
In the present day they have given
their name to a particularly extreme
kind of obstacle race,
which challenges people to achieve
their own athletic and physical best
in the face of enormous hardship.
What is more, Spartan women were just
as tough and as strong as the men.
We're told by the ancient sources
that they exercised,
they received an education,
and they were able to own
property in their own right.
All things denied to the women
of other parts of Greece.
However, I think there are some ways
in which we need to hesitate
before accepting the Spartans
as the perfect icon
of our modern values today.
First, they can become figureheads
of the xenophobe.
The Battle of Thermopylae can start
to stand for holding out against
the encroachment of an alien invader.
The most pernicious example
of the Spartans usage of this kind
is in 1930s Germany, when they came
to stand for the ancestry of the
Aryan master race and essentially
legitimated anti-Semitism
and other extreme forms
of xenophobia.
Another question is whether we today
really want to claim the Spartan
paradigm of masculinity.
Emotion was anathema.
The individual was nothing.
The state was everything.
As we realise more and more the need
to encourage people to express rather
than deny their emotions and to show
the distress they might be feeling,
maybe the Spartan ideal
of masculinity is not the one
we actually want to claim
for the present day.
It's no coincidence that the Spartans
inspired the British public school
system of the 19th
and early 20th Centuries.
A system in which ideals of
discipline, endurance and austerity
were paramount.
Even the toughness
of Spartan women is suspect.
The ancient sources tell us that they
trained their bodies to produce
strong sons, so even the athleticism
for which they were famous
serves ultimately
the Spartan war machine.
And the grim joy with which they
saw their sons go to their deaths
in battle is unpalatable today.
Spartan women are said, by the
author Plutarch, to have told their
menfolk going off to war...
On one's shield
of course meant dead.
Evoking Sparta is often a way
of trying to recover values which
are thought to be lost or receding.
Old fashioned values
of resilience and self-denial,
which some in modern society
feel that we have squandered.
In fact, however, historians of
ancient Sparta have long challenged
the historical truthfulness of the
ancient stereotype of the Spartans.
For decades now, they have been
trying to put forward an alternative
Sparta with a richer,
more complex culture.
Art, music and a much more
complex range of values
than have traditionally been
attributed to them.
There is no sign however
of this happening.
We are too addicted to the Spartan
stereotype, however inaccurate,
to give it up in favour of a more
complex and nuanced reality.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!